hey jelly what's up oh except oh my god
Jim last night Ryan and I totally
finally hooked up it was awesome that's
great really I know it was so funny cuz
we were at this bar with his friends and
I was sitting next to him the whole
night and it wasn't making a move so in
my head I was like Ryan what's taking so
long and then he kissed me and I didn't
know what to say
so I said Ryan what took you so long and
he just said to him can you believe that
oh my god Jim is that embarrassing I'm
embarrassed no don't be oh thank god I
was nervous damn you will not believe
how nervous but now now I have a
boyfriend
alright yeah I hooked up with her on
February 13th
[Music]
what Oh
Pam's on vacation and she gets back
tomorrow so it'll be nice to see her
it'll be nice and she set a date for the
wedding with Roy June summer so that'll
be nice and that's that what Oh
Jim has been looking at me kind of a lot
all week I would be creeped out by it
but it's nothing compared to the way
Michael looks at me I drink like a
hundred iced macchiatos a day and
practically nothing else there's a
really cool coffee place jitters at the
Steamtown mall if you've been there know
you've ever been to jitters Brian you
are so dorky give me your number a
second sexy come on let me know dress I
think something a little fishy is going
on fishy
that little girl is a child I don't want
to see you sniffing around her anymore
this afternoon do you understand boy
have you lost your mind cause I'll help
you find what you're looking for
nobody gonna help you out there Jesus
can come through that door he's not
gonna help you if you don't stop
sniffing after my child okay Stanley
yelled at me today that was one of the
most frightening experiences of my life
hi guys
does everyone know my boyfriend Bob
Vance Kevin Malone Bob Vance Vance
refrigeration Stanley Hudson Bob Vance
Vance refrigeration Ryan Howard Bob
Vance Vance refrigeration her line and
work you and Bob know I know we left the
other day on a note of uncertainty but
after some more thought I'm very pleased
to be able to offer you this job great
I'm so glad we're all very excited
you're gonna be joining us it'll be nice
to have another MBA around here I'm
excited too
okay bye nobody you and I are done what
so it plays on the Infinity thing
without being obvious yeah definitely um
I'd love to do like a color version just
bring a little color I like it a lot
it's clear and subtle at the same time
it's really good you have a real talent
for this stuff Thanks I'd love to talk
to you about it more that'd be great
do you want to go out to dinner tonight
oh is it more something nice no what um
I just I just wanted him dinner I'm uh
I'm dating Jim you're kidding
we're together that's great that's
awesome yeah
so let me uh yeah let me look at these
okay great great
I guess he can't get any Carolina wants
hello until you actually got this
presentation ready why don't you sent a
ssin because I don't want to do what I
really want
honestly Michael is for you to know it
so that you can communicate it to the
people here to your clients to whomever
okay what it's whoever not whomever
that's whomever no whomever is never
actually right not sometimes it's right
Michael is right it's a made-up word
used to trick students no actually
whomever is the formal version of the
word
obviously it's a real word but I don't
know when to use it correctly not a
native speaker I know what's right but
I'm not gonna say because you're all
jerks who didn't come see my band last
night do you really know which one is
correct
I don't know its whom when it's the
object of the Sanderson who when is the
subject that sounds right well it sounds
right but is it as about as an object is
me as an object is you weight above babe
how did he use it again it was Brian
would have Michael the subject to
explain the computer system the object
guilt to whomever meaning us the
indirect object which is the the correct
usage over work no one asked you
anything ever so whomever his name is
Toby why don't you take a letter opener
and stick it into your school wait this
doesn't matter and I don't even care
Michael you quit the other job you're
fired here oh my gosh yes well this is
what happened Ryan's big project was the
website which wasn't doing so well so
Ryan to give the impression of sales
recorded them twice once his office
sales and once his website sales which
is what we refer to the business as
misleading the shareholders another good
term is fraud
how's my favorite branch doing all right
ronnie was breath things were at an
all-time sad here but then I got an
email from Ryan that he was coming back
to town and I called the temp agency and
I told them I will pay you any amount to
just give me Ryan Howard give him to me
I want him I need him and you got a
goatee I did did you get that after you
help me move in you saw mine yes
goatee fire guy hey Kevin that's really
funny yeah it's great to see you keV you
too I'm keeping a list of everyone who
wrongs me so when I'm back on top
they'll be sorry Kevin just made the
list Jim I want to apologize for how I
treated you last year I lost sight of
myself and now that I've quit the rat
race I realized there's so much more to
life than being the youngest VP in the
company's history I've even started on
volunteering giving back to the
community that's great you're talking
about your court-ordered community
service I don't need a judge to tell me
to keep my community clean but he did
right all right
there's always been a like one Michael
what's going on hi hey Ryan
yeah excuse me yes this wasn't on the
list yes it is no yes it's not it is
when did you add the sillas Sam everyone
deserves a second second chance Ryan
just out of curiosity how much you get
paid here $60,000 a year you get paid by
the year at the bowling alley do you
make secretary back to work shoe [ __ ]
told you guys are really busy here would
you like to come to work for the Michael
Scott Paper Company
what's that shoes you guys I'm not one
of those men's 10 showi okay okay he's
already paying for himself where is it
for you hey come on guys these are prime
selling Oz you know
I imagine one of the best things about
being an IT guys you get to know
everyone's computer passwords you know I
actually don't listen I know you have to
say that but we got a little problem
here there is an employee named Jim
Halpert and he's doing some terrible
things
okay he is molesting people via the
internet and we need to stop him I think
that you should call the cops so the
cops called us so I'm gonna need you to
give me the password see Jim Halpert
computer I don't know what to tell you
man I'm sorry I just can't give out his
password like that I think we could make
things very very difficult for you are
you you threatening me threatening you
No
you